for this video I'll primarily be
focusing on the negatives for this
series because obviously all the set
pieces production design and VFX are
stellar and at times the writing is
alright but most of the time it's not
great there were so many scenes plot
lines and developments that simply
didn't really matter in the grand scheme
of things primarily in regards the
numenor politics and Side characters and
the entirety of the harfoot's plot line
to me the biggest issue with the show is
the feeling of disconnection and lack of
unifying goal between each plot line
naturally the battle against the Orcs or
the creation of the Rings should be the
primary focus of a show called The Rings
of power but that was barely half of the
show if that the other half Falls
inconsequential and pointless material
that will lead people bored and wanting
more why do we need so many scenes with
the hard foots they all blend together
in one meaningless mesh of nothingness I
don't need to be reminded how the hard
foots leave people behind a million
times or them collecting and devouring
food no one cares about the way of life
of this one random community that won't
tie into the rest of what is to come in
the future this would be like spending
over two hours within the Hobbit
Community for the Lord of the Rings
trilogy it's flat out filler it's nice
to get some World building but that
shouldn't be the prime emphasis of the
show the only character here of value is
the stranger but nothing happens in the
season for him to impact a larger story
as a whole besides us figuring out who
he is that's why to me the season feels
so much like a prologue if you look at
the lure of the Rings which had a total
of about nine hours to tell its Story
the trilogy never loses focus and you're
always engaged in a unifying objective
that binds everyone together and that
conflict was epic and fun and this
season of the Rings of power that almost
had the same amount of time we had one
small scale fight against the Legion of
Orcs And an incredibly rushed ending for
the whole mithril developments which
I'll get into a second and I'll mark the
time codes with spoilers but this season
didn't have that big of an event to
build up to and if it was supposed to be
the fight with the DARS Army then it was
kind end of underwhelming besides the
ending of that episode which was really
good but the fact that the writers
failed to tie in different subplots and
give them purpose inherently Make Scenes
boring even for scenes in numenor where
we are following different characters
they're all drastically underdeveloped
and nothing really happens with them
this is also accentuated by the fact
that they are making every side
character numenor a POV character where
we have whole scenes with each of them
but yet the writers fail to make us care
for them and make them interesting the
only thing of value in terms of
characterization that happens is a
soldier taking the blame for his friends
and even then that was kind of it
everyone else here is extremely Bland
even the politics are so black and white
to the point that you can't have any
Intrigue here ah yes this guy hates
Elves and the current Queen is in favor
of elves hmm I wonder where this plot
line is going and the funny thing is is
that that development doesn't even get
resolved for season one despite us
having so many scenes there along with
his seal door and even Duran not showing
up in the finale it just randomly ends
with a major Revelation and then the
critters pull the plug without resolving
much else they had to spend so much time
with the hard foots that it feels like
they robbed the rest of the plot lines
for screen time for the final episode
let me put this into perspective we
spend just as much time with the hard
foots than we did with the creation of
the Rings of power which to me is pretty
insane and I may as well go into this
now so spoilers for the final episode
the whole development with halbron
actually being Sauron was so messy and
quickly done that it left me genuinely
confused how the hell does Cilla brimbor
one of the best smiths in Middle Earth
not no basic things relating to Alloys
why does he trust this random person
from the Southlands to work on a top
secret project that even the hiking of
the elves slide to alrond's about why
didn't Sauron easily lie to Galadriel
and say he took the king seal or
whatever off a dead corpse and further
manipulate her instead of immediately
spilling the beans and saying he's
Sauron how did this man suddenly
teleport report back to Mordor there's
just so many aspects about this that are
underdeveloped that it's wild to me that
the writers didn't spend more time here
to flesh things out shouldn't the
manipulation of sorry be deeper than
this and the creation of the Rings of
power take more time instead of it being
done in like 20 minutes this seems like
the most interesting aspect of the story
but the writers would rather spend more
time on the hard foots from what I've
seen from the lore since I don't know
much about it given that I'm kind of a
casual fan is that sarin was disguised
and heavily manipulated celebrembor for
a long duration then slowly over time
they figured out his identity given that
there's already a lot of established
lore that people love I don't really
understand why the writers are taking so
many divergences from The Source
material I would go in depth about that
but I mainly want to focus on the show
so going into another aspect that
heavily brings down the show's quality
is the amount of inconsistencies with
the writing and major contrivances that
are needed to tell the story two
contrivances that bug me the most are
glad randomly running into halbern on
the Open Sea and them also running into
a numenor ship the likelihood of that
happening is practically impossible and
given the reveal of who how brand is
makes this coincidence even more absurd
and I hit the [ __ ] writer's pull
where no this isn't a contrived piece of
writing but instead it's Destiny so the
excuse anything that has no chance to
happen with this another major
contrivance comes within the finale
where gnoring her Entourage go up
against the spooky wizard ladies and
somehow survive like can't they just
absolutely wipe the floor with them this
would be like Luke Skywalker getting
rolled by Ewoks these are immensely
powerful beings wielding magic and
they're having trouble dispatching some
midgets with rocks and in what world
would the harfords want to confront
these powerful beings let alone anyone
their plan just consisted of making bird
noises and sneaking The Stranger out did
they actually think that was going to
work the plot armor here is too much to
bear and even the magic is poorly
executed and and is not creatively used
taking a look at some inconsistencies we
have the Orcs burning in the sunlight as
a starter in episode 4 an entire escape
from the Orcs hinders on the fact that
they are burnt by sunlights and can't
pursue our protagonists into an open
field and even before this while digging
trenches they had to put up covers so
they don't get nuked by the sun however
in episode 6 all the Orcs are outside in
broad daylight fighting like they have
no limitations from the Sun the only
logical explanation for this is that the
clouds magically come out when the Orcs
have to be outside for a scene but that
is inherently bad writing on its own not
to mention that some of the coverage for
the scene is shot in direct sunlight so
these Orcs should be melting according
to what the show set up you could also
argue that the cloaks they are wearing
blocks of sunlight but then that
wouldn't make sense in episode 4 where
they couldn't go out of the forest and
even if they could tolerate the sunlight
for a short duration then surely they
could have just run up to them captured
them and brought them back to the forest
quickly then there's also the general
strength of the orc army or Legion it's
never really clear how strong they are
and it seems like Orcs are spawning out
of nowhere I thought most of them died
in the tower but I guess there were a
lot more sitting around in the forest
another inconsistency is the passage of
time within the show during episode 6
galagio numenorous forces seemingly get
from the Sun during sea all the way into
the Southlands in about a day's time or
like 10 minutes of screen time that on
its own is pretty ridiculous especially
since it didn't seem like that much time
has passed for the people in the
Southlands I feel like the writers were
panicking here and were quickly trying
to merge these two plot lines together
for some plot armor around here freezes
off against a brood of an orc and
instead of easily killing around Deer he
just tosses him around I see this a lot
in different shows and movies where the
antagonists can easily kill their
protagonists but chooses not to for
convenient reasons the last example I
remember was in the book of Boba Fett
where Boba Fett was basically naked an
assassin decides to just eat him around
a room instead of you know assassinating
him when it becomes clear that the
antagonistic force is toothless and
bears no danger to any characters
there's really no tension in these
action scenes because you know the
heroes are safe you can kill as many
random background characters as you want
but as long as you do something like
this then you invalidate the threat
level of the villain that and the threat
level of the Orcs is extremely
inconsistent it reminds me of the whites
from Game of Thrones where on one hand
they can instantly kill background
characters with ease and then on the
other they can become incompetent when
trying to kill the main characters
whether these Orcs are Archer Pros
sniping people left and right or an orc
just blindly wailing on a fallen soldier
who should be very easy to kill the Orcs
power level seem to drastically shift as
the writers demand it in any given scene
then there's also the moment where Adar
lets around here go for the sole reason
of delivering a message like why not
send back one of the humans why send a
valuable Elven soldier who is wrecking
your Orcs earlier to go back to your
enemy so he can fight again it painfully
comes across as this character having
plot armor and the writers needing him
to give the humans a Fighting Chance
despite it being very contrived then
after all of this when the volcano
explodes how do most of these people
survive the volcanic blasts and
Firestorm following it like galagios is
standing outside brute forcing that [ __ ]
do elves also have resilient skin too
then in regards to Deus Ex machinas two
back-to-back contrived moments happen to
save Theo's life in episode 4. firstly a
runter comes out of the Shadows to save
Theo he was supposed to be going back to
the Tower and I don't know why he's
stealthing around the village this isn't
his objective by any means and has no
Intel that there should be people here
not to mention that it's very dangerous
to be doing this wouldn't it make more
sense to get to the Tower and Bronwyn
tells a rondir that Thea went to the
village and is now missing and that's
why Aranda goes to the Village to save
Theo then after for saving Theo Bronwyn
ends up miraculously running into them
in the forest which doesn't make sense
at all unless she put like a tracking
chip on him or something there are a lot
of these small writing flaws that may go
unnoticed to some people but since there
are so many of them it really calls
attention to how bad the writing is at
times they basically run the entire
gambits and make every mistake in the
book scenes can be enjoyable and they're
a very brief good moments Within These
episodes but any bad and glaring
mistakes can overshadow the good writing
aspects in the show Because the actual
good scenes paired with the outstanding
production value gives you a brief
Glimpse as to how good the show can be
but it gets bogged down by bad writing
filler and a lack of overall Stakes to
tie everything together with more
meaning looking at the characters and
the entirety of the season the only
pairing I liked was jurn and ailerons
and even then their relationship was
still underdeveloped by that I mean they
basically go from just warming up to
each other again to Dern crying and
getting sad that his friend isn't
leaving him it feels like their bond was
pretty rushed but their scenes together
have a lot of chemistry there are snarky
remarks towards each other and being
able to make each other laugh breathes
life into the show that it desperately
needs then it's also wholesome that they
value their friendship over the
responsibilities to their own societies
truly a great Duo and it seems like
they're the only people that are having
fun in the show because when we go from
them to Collateral and literally any
other character it's a chore to watch
galadro and of herself is easily the
worst character because the entire
essence of her is a contradiction how is
this elf who is extremely old by this
point in the story so childish stubborn
aggressive arrogant and at times stupid
the scene where she's talking to the
council at numenor being extremely
disrespectful to the queen is so cringe
inducing because this is how a child
would act though she have no respect for
anyone or how people perceive her then
when the writers try to give her a good
moment where she's quote unquote
training soldiers she's on not actually
training them and it's just using this
moment as an opportunity to destroy them
and show off her abilities like ah yes
this war hero who has been fighting for
many years is dunking on these new
recruits who have little fighting
experience this would be like Michael
Jordan playing against kids in
basketball what would have been a good
scene where she cares about educating
soldiers and fighting a harsh enemy
instead comes across as someone stroking
their own ego and this was the only
scene with a numenor that was somewhat
interesting because it related back to
the larger stakes in Middle Earth but
all the useful information as the orc
weaknesses falls into the background now
I love a good strong independent female
character but when the creators are
making silly slow motion shots of her
doing literally anything like walking
onto a ship with her armor on is dumb
you don't need to force my perception of
the character through obnoxious editing
and instead allow the writing to do that
for Iran deer he never evolves outside
of the stereotypical Soldier and he
feels like a bland POV character for us
to follow in battle for how much screen
time he gets I'm surprised the writers
didn't give the guy more to do because
even the thing that was giving his
characters some form of life which was
his romance with Bronwyn essentially
falls into the background not saying
that it was good to begin with but that
was really all he had outside of
fighting Orcs the side characters with a
numenor I think will never really become
that interesting because they don't have
much to do in the larger story nor does
anything happen with a numenor plot wise
that is really intriguing at all so any
character who receives screen time here
is immediately fighting an uphill battle
to entertain the audience because we
would rather be somewhere else in the
worlds then lastly we have the harfoots
and I don't really mind them that much
as characters because they are at least
Lively it's just that they have no
relevance to the overall story given the
end point for them in this season though
I hope the writers can give them more to
do in season two because if it's the
same as season 1 then it's going to be
rough I don't think I need to make this
video overly long because the first
season of the Rings of power essentially
feels like a prologue and the better
material will hopefully come later just
their execution of it is not very solid
and the writing patterns within season 1
are not promising this also isn't to say
that you can't have a good prologue
because that's also kind of what the
house of the Dragon is too it's a
prolong log to the dance of dragons but
the difference here is that the story is
extremely focused the characters are
significantly richer and the pace is
definitely not slow to say the least and
there's no filler at all every scene
serves a direct purpose everything has
meaning and there are major plot points
that happen more frequently to keep the
audience entertained on top of there
being a big endpoint that we're heading
towards that everyone is excited for to
me the rings of power doesn't fulfill
most of that and it makes the show a bit
of a slog to get through at times the
production design of the show is great
and has some stunning VFX but that can
only uplift the show so far when the
scripts are lacking thank you for
watching and let me know in the comments
what you thought about the rings of
power season 1.
foreign